supreme court justice clarence thomas
issuing a big warning today about the
future of u.s elections
justice thomas dissenting as the high
court ruled 6-3
not to review two pennsylvania
presidential election cases
thomas argued the court should look at
the cases to resolve whether
non-legislators like
election officials or courts have any
power to set election rules like easing
mill and voting restrictions
writing these cases provide us with an
ideal opportunity to address
just what authority non-legislative
officials have to set election rules
and to do so well before the next
election cycle the refusal to do so
is inexplicable now thomas says it's
fortunate that election rulings by
pennsylvania supreme court
did not involve enough ballots to affect
the outcome
of the 2020 election but he argued
changes to mail-in voting or
other election rules right before an
election make the voting process prone
to fraud
and mistrust writing we failed to settle
this dispute before the election
and thus provide clear rules now we
again fail to provide
clear rules for future elections the
decision to leave election law hidden
beneath a shroud of doubt is baffling
by doing nothing we invite further
confusion and erosion of voter
confidence
our fellow citizens deserve better and
expect more
of us thomas's dissent comes as all
house democrats signed on to a new
election reform bill today
known as the for the people act
democrats say it would create
national automatic registration expand
early voting and simplify voting by mail
republicans argue it would undermine
election integrity
the bill is set to be looked at in early
march